>> Scott: On behalf of BGN and the Gayglers,
I welcome you to this at Google
presentation of None on Record.
Today, our presenter is Selly Thiam.
I'll just let her take over.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SELLY THIAM: Thank you, Scott, for having
me today.
Can you guys hear me okay?
[PAUSE]
[hums]
Is this better?
[PAUSE]
Testing.
Okay, there I am.
Okay.
So I'm actually going to tell you a little
bit about None on Record.
None on Record is an audio-based oral history
project, and it started in 2006.
And what we do as a team is we travel through
Diaspora communities in North America and
Europe, and also on the continent of Africa
to interview LGBT Africans.
But before I get into kind of the specifics
of how None on Record began and what we actually
do, I have to actually play some of the voices
of the people that we've met along the way
in the last four years since we've been collecting
oral histories.
So this is -- this is a brief cross-section
of some of the people that we've interviewed.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> A lot of us can't go home and be who we
are.
And we are in exile in some way because of
that and that doesn't make any sense to us
as Africans.
>> I couldn't walk to the shop without hearing
at least one person, some car going past
– going 'beep, beep'; 'Isn't that her?'
Yeah, bitch.
We're going to get you; you're a woman.
Faggot.
>> He said, you know you can go to the jail
for your life.
I said if you bring me in jail for my life
gay, I accept it.
>> I'm lesbian.
I don't care what other people do behind closed
doors.
It's, it's, it's their -- it's who they are
and this is who I am.
Let's, let's, let's love each other.
>> And immediately when we jump on stage and
grab that mic, we'll sing this song.
[SINGING]
And, the whole crowd would just jump and get
a standing ovation.
And, you know, what this people, they know
who they are and they know where they stand.
>> I'm disillusioned because I'm living in
South Africa, and there is so much that's
going wrong.
There's so much that has been promised that
isn't happening.
>> If they want me to go back to my country,
I will go back to my country.
And I will still doing what I starts doing
before I came here because they're still killing
gay people, lesbian people, and it's getting
worse.
>> You are nothing without the community.
And we're responsible to the ancestors, where
we must respond to those -- and when I say
ancestors, they're not dead.
They're alive and they're watching you.
>> I've had to sort of let go of the fact
that maybe I won't be on the family tree [laughs]
and that's okay.
>> But I'm African, I'm a lesbian, and I'm
an AIDS activist.
[music ends]
SELLY THIAM: So None on Record began as a
documentary.
I started collecting oral histories partly
because I am actually of Senegalese origin;
I was born here in the United States.
And it, it began as a documentary, but what
has, what has become is a network of people
all over the world who are activists, who
are artists, who are organizers, who are none
of that who have gotten caught up in very
difficult situations and had to show extreme
bravery.
But to really sort of give you the background
and the context, I have to show you a picture
of this woman.
This is Fanny Ann Eddy.
She was a very prominent activist in Sierra
Leone.
She was murdered in the offices of the Lesbian
and Gay Association in Freetown, Sierra Leone,
in 2004.
She was murdered a few months after returning
from the UN, where she gave a speech about
the rights of queer Africans on the continent,
protecting the lives of queer Africans.
She was murdered and the details of her murder
are very horrific.
Her throat was cut.
And she was raped.
Her tongue was removed from her mouth.
So in 2004, this hit the international news.
And an article was written, and it was published
in the Chicago LGBT newspaper.
So when I saw the picture, this is actually
the picture I saw in the paper, this is the
first time I was actually seeing a West African
lesbian.
And the impact of her murder and the -- the
symbolism of her murder within an African
context, had a profound impact on me.
And I didn't have any journalism training
at the time.
I didn't know how to do any audio recording.
I didn't know how to mix audio, but I knew
there was something that I wanted to do.
And, when you sort of decide that there's
something you want to do, I think that, circumstance
of the universe creates a way.
And so, I met this woman Notisha Massaquoi,
who is also from Sierra Leone.
She was born in Sierra Leone, and she was
raised in Toronto, Canada.
I went to a conference about violence in Third
World communities and she gave a speech about
a friend of hers who had been murdered in
Sierra Leone in the offices of the LGBT Association
there and happened to be Fanny Ann Eddy.
So when I returned to Chicago, I decided that
I would drive to Toronto and I would interview
this woman.
So she was very gracious and let me into her
home in Toronto.
And this was the first interview that I took
for the None on Record project.
[PAUSE]
>> NOTISHA MASSAQUOI(on audio tape): I was
very connected with Fanny Ann Eddy who founded
the Sierra Leone Lesbian and Gay Association.
She did a lot of activist work internationally.
She spoke at the UN about rights for queer
Africans across the continent.
And someone broke into the office of the organization
and stabbed her and mutilated her body, which
had such an enormous impact and really changed
my life.
I had to sit down and assess what was I doing
here in Canada with all of these privileges
and all of these rights.
In Canada, we could get married as gay people.
We have streets and bars and all kinds of
things that we can engage in without worrying
about dying.
And she was in Sierra Leone doing this work,
knowing that she could go to jail just for
loving another woman.
I felt my silence enabled her to be murdered
in that way.
All of our silence enabled her to be murdered
She was so out and so public and she was out
there by herself.
And if we were all out there to support us,
they'd have to kill all of us.
You know what I mean?
Not just, okay, there's only one we can target,
let's get her.
It was at that point that I was just really,
really driven and committed to doing this
work.
SELLY THIAM: Since then Notisha Massaquoi
actually has become our president of our board
of directors, but she was the first interview
that None on Record collected.
And she was actually the first interview to
be broadcast on National Public Radio in 2007.
So it was kind of -- it's an important story
to me as a person who was born in Diaspora
because we both felt so disconnected from
what was going on the African continent.
There wasn't a lot of information coming in
at the time about the organizing that was
happening there, but there was a lot of organizing
happening there.
Since then more information has come, has
come to -- to the, to the forefront.
But we both at that moment, after the interview,
kind of before it even got put on Public Radio,
knew that something was happening, that we
would be part of creating something.
And so I came back to the States, shocked
myself by having it on Public Radio.
She didn't really know what NPR was.
Because of my youthful disposition she thought
it was a college radio station.
So when her, when her interview was actually
broadcast her uncle called her from Chicago.
So I mean I tried to explain what NPR was
but I should have probably used things like
CBC or something like that.
Her uncle called her and he didn't get upset.
He just said, "You really, you really portrayed
the family very well.
And I was very proud of you to tell these
stories."
So that was, that was my first interview.
And None on Record was born.
So then I decided I wanted to find more queer
Africans.
And I didn't know where any were besides Notisha.
So I began to do Google searches, do different
kinds of research, and I came upon this person,
Nick Mwaluko.
Nick actually was born in Tanzania and was
raised in Kenya.
Nick also was born biologically female, and
since moving -- well, before moving to the
United States transitioned into becoming a
male but was living his life as a male in
Kenya.
What actually happened was when he moved to
the States, the relationship between masculinity
for him in Kenya was very different than how
he was -- he wasn't seen as a man here.
So he started to kind of have this reaction
that he wanted to be able to feel like he
was a man again.
He also has a very interesting story because
he came to New York to, to study play writing
at Columbia University.
He got an MFA in play writing.
And he also wrote and directed a beautiful
play called 'Why Africa', about a Kenyan chief's
daughter who falls in love with a white Peace
Corps volunteer.
And actually that's how I found Nick; I went
to see his play.
And then sort of stalked him for awhile until
he gave me an interview.
[laughs]
And he's an extremely private person, so I
was very surprised when he
invited him into his house in Washington Heights.
So let's hear some of that story.
>> Can you describe how to was to maneuver
as a man in Kenya?
>> NICK MWALUKO (on audio tape): There's certain
duties that you don't do if you're a man,
and certain friends.
And you don't really, like, come up to a woman
and you're friends and you hang out together
in the village.
You go to a woman for a specific reason --
I mean it's for romantic reasons, do you
know?
So it was easy.
I understood the zones.
I understood the space.
I understood how to conduct the space.
I had trousers I wore.
I wore always an over vest.
So I … you do what you do -- your hair is
short.
You rarely talk.
You -- whenever you have a conversation, you
don't look the other guy in the eye.
Sit with your legs apart.
There's like certain things you need to do.
It's easy to perform it there.
So there's new tactics, new strategies.
And, and plus I had friends who showed me
the way.
A lot of them were very, very generous in
helping me navigate this.
And they used to say, "You are my brother,
you are my son, you are my best friend who's
a guy."
And so there's like this is a mistake.
And we're going to help you rectify the mistake.
So I came to the States.
I didn't come specifically to transition,
but butches made it very difficult for me.
[laughs]
>> SELLY: And describe that some.
>> NICK: There, there -- where I grew up there
were no butches.
And so if somebody looked like me, they were
a boy.
There was nothing to contrast, nothing to
compare with.
So that was – so it was kind of easy.
So I came to the States, and people were like,
"No, no. You're butch and you're that."
And I said, "Well no, I'm a man."
And I knew and when I made love with women,
I was a man.
>> SELLY: So when you do go back to Kenya,
how do you think that's gonna go?
>> NICK: I don't know, I don't know.
>> SELLY: Do you want to go back one day?
>> NICK: Oh yeah, sure.
I will -- I'll go back.
It's my home.
SELLY THIAM: So I interviewed Nick in 2007,
and he has not gone back to Kenya yet.
He has not returned.
Partly because he's, he's physically transitioned
so much that he is a little bit nervous about
how he will be received by his family, which
is understandable.
He, also, in some ways was – he'll tell
-- he tells the story much better than I,
but a part of his coming to the States was
so he would return money to his family in
the village and he did actually spend a lot
of his money going through his transition.
So there's some, some issues around that as
well.
But Nick's story of isolation is one that
I heard a lot in the Diaspora, particularly
in North America and parts of Europe.
And it wasn't really the last time I would
hear these stories because it was sort of
a theme that sort of went through all the
countries that I've had the opportunity to
visit there.
So I know when I hear this story, I often
ask myself what it must be like to not be
able to return home.
And it's something that I don't know personally,
but I feel, I feel very much compassion for
what Nick has to go through in this area.
So I'm actually gonna move.
We're gonna go to a different country.
We're gonna go to South Africa.
In 2008, I believe, we received our first
grant, which was amazing to us that people
were giving us money to do this at this point,
and it funded our trip to South Africa.
I -- actually, Notisha Massaquoi went with
me to South Africa.
And when we got there, we knew no one in South
Africa, we did not know how we were going
to do this work, we did not know who we were
going to meet.
And we were very fortunate to meet a woman
named Thokozani Ndaba, who is somewhat of
a socialite and who knew everyone.
So we met the person who was plugged in, and
then she introduced us to everyone that we
needed to know.
So we met this woman named Beverly Ditsie.
And at the time, I didn't realize how important
this interview was going to be.
Beverly Ditsie, this is a picture from 1990.
And she was very much, she was part of the
organizing committee that organized the first
Pride March on the African continent in 1990.
And it was at the sort of the end of apartheid,
the country was changing.
She was about 19 years old.
And South Africa being a multi-racial country,
she was part of an organizing committee that
was white, was black, was South Asian.
People coming from other countries to support
the organizing of this march.
So she simply said, once she looked at the
line of speakers, "There are no Africans,
there are no black Africans speaking, so we
should probably get some to speak."
And they said, "Yeah, you should do it."
So this is kind of what happened after she
decided to take that on.
>> BEVERLY DITSIE: I didn't even get asked
to speak at the first Pride March.
I think it, it's one of those things where
I asked them why it was that there was no
woman of color, girl of color, who's gonna
be part of the representation.
Because if it's only gonna be white people
up on the podium in, in the first Pride March
in Africa, then what it is white influence
nonstop.
So I think I just asked.
I was like, wouldn't it help us to have a
black person?
It was like, "Yeah, yeah. Yah!! You want to
do it? You want to make a speech?"
So I made a speech.
Those cameras, those cameras around me didn't
mean anything until it hit the news.
Whoa, church groups, school groups, parents
groups, teachers groups, you name it.
Everywhere was like a whole petition to get
me killed, to get people like me.
It was like we understand when it's these
white people.
We understand it's a very white thing to be
doing.
So we understand.
But when you stand up and tell us it's also
African, oh, you're starting to insult people's
sensibilities, and you're shaking their moral
ground, and you're shaking their own firm
beliefs.
It was a frightening time.
The threat to my family, threat to my mother,
the threat to my grandma and my sister.
Guys coming around my house wanting to teach
me I'm a woman, and that was something I did
not expect.
Like I couldn't walk to the shop without hearing
at least one person or some car going past
and going beep, beep. "Is that her? Yeah,
bitch, we're going to get you.
You're a woman.
Faggot."
You know or whatever.
Every time I heard noises outside I kept thinking,
am I being attacked?
Because people were threatened.
They would say to me, "We're coming for you."
That actually got my parents completely and
totally supporting me.
Because the implications were if they don't
support me, then who is?
Who is going to? Who's gonna?
You know.
So my grandma became my rock.
That is why when eventually the big group
of men surrounded my house and said, "We're
coming to get her" and they tried to walk
through the gate, and she said, "Walk in.
Just try it. Just try it."
And she called to my Great Aunt Kate, "Bring
the thing."
She's talking about, like, a thick iron thing.
I mean, if she had a baseball bat, it would
be a baseball bat.
But they thought there was something else
going on.
And they kind of stopped and when the momentum
in the group dynamics, when the momentum's
gone, and somebody goes, "Maybe we should
leave."
They left.
So I was escorted for about two weeks after
the march.
My mom would put on her Converse, her Chuck
Taylor's, and she'd put on her jeans.
And she's say, "All right. You need to go
there? Let's walk."
I was scared all the time.
So yeah, just pushed so hard and stuck out
like a sore thumb.
And said, "All right. Look, I'm here and I
ain't moving. I ain't budging."
SELLY THIAM: Because of activists like Bev
Ditsie and Simon Uncoli, South Africa eventually
passed one of the most progressive constitutions
in the world.
They allow for gay marriage and protection
of rights for LGBT people.
But even with the very progressive constitution,
the amount of violence that LGBT people face
in the townships and across the country is
staggering.
Not to mention just the violence against women
in general.
I'm not sure if you've all heard of the corrective
rapes that happen to a lot of the lesbian
women who live in the townships and other
parts of the country.
But we did meet a lot of women who did tell
us these stories of being put into these situations
of corrective rapes by people they had grown
up and seen most of their lives.
So there's still a lot of -- and also gay
men and trans-people also face a lot of the
same forms of violence there.
So there's a lot of work to, to be done still.
And the organizing in South Africa, it's,
it's amazing.
I mean, there are so many people who are organizing
around LGBT equity there.
And so it was, it was an incredible place
to be, to see this happen on the African continent.
So since then they've had many Gay Prides.
They've turned – they start as marches,
of course, and have turned into these huge
Pride events with beer commercials and half-naked
people.
And Bev Ditsie herself said she doesn't go
anymore because it's lost its political message.
But she was very instrumental in making that
happen.
So through this work, I want to say, collecting
oral histories for two years and traveling
to different countries, I started to really
ask myself what does it really mean to go
somewhere and collect a story?
Because usually these interviews are about
two hours long, and then I cut them down to
these, these vignettes that you're listening
to.
This is from different parts of interviews
that I have with people so it takes a while
to produce them.
But then I would distribute them, or they
would go on Public Radio.
Or someone else will want to distribute them,
but I kept thinking to myself that what does
it mean to go somewhere and then just take
the stories from that place?
I mean, what else, what else can we do to
give back?
So actually after coming back from South Africa,
and Thokozani Ndaba, who I mentioned earlier,
who plugged us into this community became
our first -- she began to lead our first satellite,
which is None on Record in South Africa.
So what she does there is she works with a
lot of the young women in townships, she collects
oral histories from a lot of Africans who
have immigrated to South Africa, and she also
is learning and teaching a lot of production
skills.
So I'm gonna play an interview that she actually
recorded in Capetown and edited herself.
So South Africa actually is our first satellite;
Canada became a satellite later.
I'm gonna play an interview from Canada after
this and soon later this year we'll be starting
work in Nairobi.
So it's become like I said in the beginning,
it was a documentary that has become a network.
And is also a way for people, because I had
also no formal training to sort of teach these
like citizen journalism models.
Like how do you collect your own history?
How do you find ways to tell an alternative
story?
So with that I'm going to play Carlos Idibouo,
who was part of our Seeking Asylum project.
He is from the Ivory Coast.
He now lives in Montreal; at the time he lived
in Toronto.
As we were traveling, we heard a lot of stories
from people who had to -- had to flee their
home countries and Carlos had a similar situation.
So he was part of our Seeking Asylum project
where we, we specifically focused on people
who were looking for refugee, refugee status
or were trying to attain refugee status or
asylum in the United States.
So I'm gonna play Carlos'. OK?
>> CARLOS IDIBOUO: (audio tape) We start organizing
ourself in 2003, because we have so many capable
dying from AIDS.
Almost every month, some people call me to
tell that, okay, this person died and that
was really too much for me.
All the services were directed to the straight
community.
And when we talk about the work we're doing,
we're like, okay, that's not really important.
Because we already have a very big program
about HIV, so you guys don't really need a
special program for your community.
But those people didn't know what's were the
realities for the gay and lesbian people in
Africa.
Many people experience homophobia in hospital,
especially for the transfer status people.
Any time they go there, they are targeted
with the nurses, with doctors, so they just
decide to stop going to hospital.
And because I was traveling a lot for some
workshop, for some conference across Africa,
I wasn't always there to go with them to hospital,
and they were very scared to go alone.
So their health was getting very bad.
And in two months, five people who were living
with me died from AIDS.
In this same time, just because of homophobia,
just because they're scared to be rejected
by their family, the other members of their
condition; they didn't want to come out, to
speak, to talk at the radio, to talk on the
TV, to do some interviews with some newspaper.
So I was alone.
And that was really, really too much for me.
When I finished work, and I go home, sometimes
I find some letters under my door saying that,
"Okay, you should move from here because we
don't need gay people to be our, our neighbor."
So in three months, I moved like four times.
And I said, "Okay. I think it's time for me
to move somewhere."
I didn't know exactly where to go.
But I got two scholarship for the Out Games
in 2006, and the AIDS conference here in Toronto.
And so when I came, I didn't plan to stay
in Canada.
I don't even know where I am.
I don't know what is going on here.
But with struggling a lot, doing activism
in Africa, I think what I did gave me the
strength to stay here in Canada.
And what I was thinking about through this
process was all the work I did in my country
in the gay community.
Who is gonna continue this work?
People are dying.
And I left the situation like that to come
here in Canada.
I felt guilty about that.
Years are passing, but homophobia is still
getting high and they're still killing gay
people, lesbian people, in so many countries,
the governments doesn't care.
They even establish some laws against gay
and lesbian community.
They're still, they're still doing that, and
it's getting worse.
So I think there is a lot of work to do in
Africa and here.
But I still thinking about Africa.
I still thinking about Ivory Coast.
SELLY THIAM: So when we took this interview,
he hadn't received his refugee status in Canada.
And a few months afterwards, he did receive
it.
And he actually moved to French-speaking part
of Canada, so that he could do more organizing
in the French community there.
He's thriving but he still feels very much
like he wishes that he could go home and do
the work there.
I'm going to play one last interview before
I wrap up today.
This is Victor Mukasa.
And Victor describes himself as a gender nonconforming
person.
Victor was born female as well.
And has transitioned into -- he uses pronouns
"him," "he," – into being male.
Victor is really interesting because he was
a very prominent LGBTI rights defender in
Uganda.
He started several LGBTI organizations there
and was very vocal.
And what happened was a young school girl
committed suicide after she was abused, sort
of physically attacked, after a group of students
found love letters that she and another young
woman were sharing.
So Victor got on the, on the radio in Uganda
and decided to speak out, which caused huge
controversy in the country.
People would come outside the radio station
and wait for him to attack him.
Radio stations got fined for having him speak
on the sta – on the radio.
In 2005, the police raided his house, and
took things from his house trying to prove
that he was a lesbian.
And at that point, he decided that he had
had enough.
And he decided to sue the Ugandan government
and so this is Victor's story.
>> VICTOR MUKASA: (audio) In 2006 when I moved
here, prior to that, I was in hiding in Uganda
because around that period, I was suing the
government of Uganda for infringing on my
rights after the government agents raided
my house.
When they came to my house, they just, they
just broke into the house.
And then if, if you looked at my house that
day it was like it had been annihilated, had
been hit by the tsunami, because everything
was upside down.
And, and they had taken documents from my
organization, CDs, and they claimed to be
looking for things that, that can prove that
I am a lesbian.
So for me that was not okay, even if on the
other hand, I was used to being treated that
way by the Ugandan government.
But being an activist and knowing that we
can do activism through so many ways, I felt
that I was ready at that point to take another
step and that is, sue the government for violating
my rights.
And also on behalf of others who had been
treated like that.
Life wasn't very easy for me.
So I had to live in hiding, and see natural
light only once in a while.
If I had to -- being a biological female,
sometimes I needed things specific for females.
And it was hard to me to send taxi men, like
cab drivers, for say sanitary towels and that
kind of things.
So life became so difficult.
And I felt that I needed some air to breathe,
and I needed to walk on a street once again
in my life since I had been in hiding for
a whole year.
And so I, I decided that I'd leave the country.
And so I left in June just for me to stretch
a little bit.
I, I decided to stay and wait for the lawyers
to call me back.
And so that took me a whole year of waiting
in Johannesburg.
>> Did you just win the case now?
VICTOR: Yeah, we just won.
About two hours ago I received a call from
Uganda and they're telling me that the government
has been condemned for the URS violations
against me.
I was told that the judge has used standing
human rights instruments to let the government
know what rights they have violated.
Shows that the judge judged fairly because
in a country like Uganda, if a judge is not
strong to stand for the truth, you cannot
judge a case in favor of a homosexual, or
a gender nonconforming person because who
knows what is going to happen to her now after
she's made such a judgment.
Yes, but the case has been won.
It's celebrations in Uganda.
I mean, Capetown, I just wish I was there
in Uganda, but in my heart, I'm celebrating.
SELLY THIAM: So Thokozani actually flew to
Capetown and took this interview in December
of 2008, when Victor had won the case.
So it was a huge victory for him, and for
the LGBTI community in Uganda.
He still lives in South Africa.
He works for the International Gay and Lesbian
Human Rights Commission for the East Africa
division, and has been doing work there.
And of course, has been speaking out about
the more recent issues of the anti-homosexuality
bill in Uganda, and working with people who
are still in the country -- although a lot
of people have had to leave -- still in the
country who are organizing an opposition to
that bill.
So I'm actually gonna stop now.
But I do want to say that this was the first
interview that Thokozani took for the South
Africa satellite.
And I really am very happy that we got Victor
on record.
It was a very good interview, very timely.
So we are still collecting.
We're setting up satellites in different parts
of the world.
And we probably will be collecting for a long
time.
And we distribute online through our website,
which is NoneOnRecord.com is our online distribution.
And when we do collaborations with organizations,
we also distribute through their sites, so
we support them with their technical needs
and distribute their own site as well.
So I'm going to stop now to allow for Q&A,
if anybody has any questions about None on
Record.
>> SCOTT: Why don't we take one question and
then we'll entertain questions at the reception?
>>Hi, thanks for coming.
It was real interesting, and
I think it's really great work.
I'm curious what's the meaning of the name
"None on Record"?
SELLY THIAM: Okay.
The third interview I did was with a priest,
Nigerian priest, by the name of John, who,
when I asked him if he had any names for LGBT
people from his ethnic language, which was
Yoruba, he said that he had none on record.
It was very profound because it was a long
silence and then he said, "No, I have none
on record."
And so for a long time I didn't really know
what I was going to name the project as we
got more interviews, but that moment was always
in my mind, when I was thinking about the
level of silence around some of these issues
and these identities.
And so subsequently, we named the project
None on Record after that interview.
>> SCOTT: Thank you all for coming. And there
is wine and cheese in Bakerfield which is
just out those doors.
SELLY THIAM: Great.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]